las aguas del lago ypoá en paraguay hoy
están rosadas el responsable durling una
fábrica de curtiembre local contra la
cual un habitante de la zona presentó
una denuncia formal y vo tener una
industria ahí o sea evidentemente todo
lo que ahí se pueda procesar va a
filtrar
y eso va directo a la ley por lo que va
a quedarse por el camino los habitantes
salieron a las calles temiendo a las
consecuencias que esto puede tener en su
comunidad y el ecosistema la situación
alarma en las autoridades locales es
realmente desesperante y le termina el
oxígeno de los vamos los peces se ahogan
o de lo contrario por las toxinas que
ingieren porque desearían los peces
estaban todos negros por dentro es decir
no no es más carnal lo que estamos
viviendo verdad el ministerio del
ambiente y desarrollo sostenible de
paraguay bloqueó las operaciones de la
fábrica durley y estableció medidas
correctivas que la empresa deberá
cumplir de manera inmediata por ahora
sin efecto alguno sobre el color del
agua
la empresa deberá eliminar en su
totalidad del efluente líquido que se
haya contenido en la superficie
aproximada de dos hectáreas y una vez
eliminado dicho líquido remover
totalmente los taludes y diques
construido para restituir las
condiciones naturales del área este no
es el primer caso de aguas contaminadas
en paraguay pero sin duda alguna uno de
los más impactantes